[Music]
hey hey
here we are folks we might be drunk
we're really doing it we got uh cheesy
bread homemade
sam's here and we're i guess tom papa
everybody hurrah
thanks for having me fellas
is it like are you a bread snob i know
you eat a lot of bread yeah so you'll
tell us that this sucks yeah and you
made this from scratch
holy [ __ ] you did
good for you how long have you been
baking bread
off and on it's cheaper to buy it yeah
is it
and it's better
and what is in this
sausage cheese
oh my gosh oh wow two cheeses
i'm off bread
good oh it's warm
really good
nice job
we'll just
anything with that
once sausage hits you're just like oh
yeah what brad you just can't you're
just carrying sausage right good job
would you say it if it wasn't i would
okay it was really good i have no
problem saying it when i saw it from
afar i was like i don't know that crust
looks a little pale ooh
but it's that kind of bread
you nailed it
and there's nothing people love more on
podcasts than hearing chewing
[Laughter]
my whole podcast is about like eating
with each other and like hanging out and
anything crunchy
the people i'm like that's what that's
what the podcast is right stop the
goddamn chewing yeah you would do that
with porn all i heard was smacking
and you know you you hear chewing all
your whole life yeah you're sitting with
people you're chewing yeah big deal
great job nice work what's you have
other
this is your go-to bread yeah do you
have like one bread that you've mastered
and this is it or do you [ __ ] around
with other breads
you can't go wrong
yeah you're so good oh my god very good
yeah now how did you well done you
filled this market of non-gay bread
maker lover
yeah that's pretty rare it is very rare
but if i was single it would really be a
thing
women are very attracted it's kind of a
fireman thing like a guy who bakes
in a bacon calendar yeah
you haven't been in my world for a while
the firemen who eat bread it's the
grocery calendar yeah that's right a
fireman with a sausage bread
thank you so good all right well done
you're right though like do you think
fireman chili like you do think of the
cooking
oh that's true you have a bit i love
about how like everyone's frantically
working out they don't eat bread and
you're like you're three pounds lighter
and you're miserable no one will ever
know yeah no one will ever know yeah
i was uh i was it i can name drop i was
at a a dinner before a largo set for
judd apatow's um
uh
charity show
at largo and uh we're at dinner and he's
going on vacation in like two days and
he really really really wants the
chicken parmesan he like really wants it
but he's like but i want to look good on
the boat
[Laughter]
judd
you could have five chicken parmesans
no one's gonna know yeah
in your head you feel swollen and fat
and shitty but you look for the outside
exactly the same and no one's looking at
judd for hotness you know no offense but
that ship is sailing
except for judd like in his mind i guess
right
i guess so yeah former guest former
guest oh yeah he was on him he actually
didn't do amazing
we didn't drink on that episode because
we had bert kreischer on the day before
oh oh god and he nearly killed us with
his drinking did he really he drank so
much on the app and then he's like let's
go to a bar we're like dude we're
[ __ ] dying three hours he cried
he laughed he did everything it was it
was a lot
is he uh is he i guess he's our ron
white right like he's
yeah i guess so
they're so slip
so ron was like a slow sipping whiskey
guy or tequila guy bird is like a
throw them all down party guys
the way homer simpson would eat donuts
that's burnt with alcohol
yeah and ron quit drinking i don't know
if you saw that no i didn't see so he's
like his his
crown is gone now it's all burnt so it's
all bert i guess it's like the wire
season four yeah
that's crazy wow because i remember
learning that it was legit like that ron
was legit drinking like all through the
sets
i was like oh man cause
that's like you know dean martin like
faked it right you know like he started
but then it was just like but then at
the end he was a real alcoholic got
more than he drank that was the old joke
right yeah stanhope's still hanging
we got that speaker he's still going i
mean what are we doing here today we're
doing uh dirty martinis i'm assuming
that everyone is a vodka guy here right
i like vodka yes
there we go all right i think of you as
like you're like an old school drinker
because you i see you in the top hat
sometimes at the cellar there's always a
martini so when you said you were coming
in i was like we gotta get martin yeah
thank you very much that's exactly what
i drink
yeah i love it
if everyone likes uh blue cheese olives
then it's a perfect time for it blue
cheese olives yes absolutely bring it on
oh i'm pum i need it we've done 78
podcasts today so i did that
i like uh i like it pretty dry do you
make them dry
well if it's dirty i don't usually even
use drive removal oh this guy's good
yeah that's my thing like it should be
one or the other and there's like two
centuries of like you know really
intense like really you know
knowledgeable
bartenders and mixologists and then
random viewers who will disagree with me
but i think it should be one or the
other it should either be like olive
juice or brine or a driver move right
because otherwise they're just like
contending with each other and fighting
so like
get up your nose and it's just this like
really weird taste
it's like an old new york 80s thing to
do both but uh oh really i know like
it's like a steakhouse thing yeah i
don't you know you got to really like
that vermouth taste i when i'm at home i
just rinse the ice with the vermouth and
dump it keep the ice and then
just go all the way so good rinse is a
good way to start out but um
i personally just like just like olive
juice and i never like it shaken unless
i'm doing like just straight up like
with nothing in it yeah yeah because
otherwise if you have olive juice or dry
vermouth and you shake it it has like an
effervescence and just comes up into
your nose and like fights
you really just want it like
in your mouth and not in your face
that's what she said
tom just turned so quickly
[Laughter]
you came on a good martini because the
only other app i think we did martinis
was with uh christa stefano and we did
not have beer jew so i'm pretty sure i
was drunk enough to stir them with my
finger yeah
i mean that's where the flavor is man a
lot of the old school bar center yeah
i'll tell you that that's where the
flavor is
my dad used to get drunk when i was a
kid and he would he couldn't find his
toothbrush and he would do the
did your dad ever do the toothbrush
finger oh yeah yeah that was a bad that
was a bad child when you come up when
you when you come up a little short and
you got to uh
and you got to fill the glass like
you're doing now
uh
same ice is good right you don't have to
dump and go some ice is fine honestly
like there's not nobody's been in there
you know yeah it's all good yeah i also
have to compliment you i love the
glasses because i hate when you get the
small martini glasses yeah it's dripping
over the edge and now i can't walk
through a room right if i get bumps the
drink is compromised yeah this is the
right type of martini glass come below
the
the rim my favorite is uh four martinis
and many other drinks in general is the
koopa in the
but then if you're doing a coupe then
you gotta you gotta leave the shaker
with your guests that's very fun
yeah um that is very true and like i
love when that happens as well i mean
you might as well leave the bottle as
well they do that at uh musso and franks
oh we tried to go there last time we
were now yeah so the three of us gotta
go cheers cheer the old game
yes all right good to be back
dude
wow
it's got like a thickness to it that so
the this is uh the brine from the blue
cheese olives
it's like it's a little oilier a little
bit yeah i don't want to say greasy but
it's there
but i like i love my martinis just
filthy dirty
if i'm an italian restaurant i'm saying
like make my martini like your pasta
water like yeah
i'm really briny like the ocean i want a
dirty [ __ ] of a martini yeah this is a
real horse martini
no no i want a dirty nun you know i want
dirty on the out or rather clean on the
outside dirty on the inside so there's
no bite at all so like there's no that
vodka sting
if you stir a martini enough there
shouldn't be a sting until it gets warm
it does leave a little thing on your
lips like you have chapstick yeah it
does it's nice that's what the bread is
for though
right soak it up with sausage bread you
guys are really living you're like an
old school you really do feel like an
old school drinker to me you like you're
almost like an at a place in time yeah i
feel like we all have a little of that
right but like there's certain comics
like a three maybe
mullany definitely has it
matterman yeah you do feel like you
could have been a comic today or in
1957. yeah i do feel that way i do feel
that way and that's why i'm starting to
dress this way yeah i'm starting to go
like the like i want to be like the dad
like i always say you have these images
of what you are and i'm no i'm really
the guy like at the barbecue when
there's kids around just like taking out
some money here you go
don't tell your mother don't tell your
mother you guys doing all right you're
doing all right here you go here's a
five for you here's a five for you so
i'm trying to uh incorporate that and
just kind of own it a little bit more
it's definitely a don draper on saturday
yeah we're charlie sheen on two and a
half men either way
that's the danger zone it's like no i
don't know if i want to we pray sheen
constantly on this pod we love shane i
mean imagine getting him on here i love
sheen too but i didn't like that's like
he he wore like the socks with the
like the big white socks i don't know
yeah that was horrible he was supposed
to be like the bad boy and he had a
stripe on each side whoa he's wearing a
bowling shirt and shorts
cbs what do you want him to do i know
but give the guy a leather jacket or
something i want to lean more towards
rodney like in back to school yeah that
kind of thing like the best that's like
that's
that's my role model rodney in back to
school is is like a top five comic
performance for me it's he he's on the
whole movie yeah yeah it's insane i mean
every [ __ ] line in the beginning oh
you're impossible oh yeah and you're
easy
everything
yeah exactly that's how we just all
picture the world on some level
and then like everything is like so and
then he just wrote that movie yeah just
walking in inappropriately to every
situation and then kennison was in that
one that's right kevin is the teacher
young
when they when they get in the bar fight
i think of that line consciously
drinking when he goes bring us bring us
a pitcher of beer every seven minutes
until someone passes out then bring us
one every turn
and then you start to realize when you
look at his style
uh
in dressing and all that stuff it's a
lot of golf clothes yeah it's a lot of
uh like his his upgrade from this kind
of a shirt is always a cardigan with a
wide lapel right and and red and like
red slack or like plaid
like he's like the loud caddyshack
that's what he is yeah same thing the
barrette with a pom-pom thing on top for
no reason
but it works we were watching a
caddyshack
we're watching caddyshack in the houston
improv green room it was me and gary
veeder and i have a young guy named
dewood uh who's like 19 filming us and
he's a kid yeah so we're watching
caddyshack and we're laughing our ass
off and he's like this is so cheesy
we're like you don't get it
it's rodney
at a certain point he started laughing
really hard but like yeah that's
rodney's gift is that like he will
appeal to any generation yeah that was
the yeah
he was i i said something to uh neil
brennan
uh
he was he was talking about uh guys who
made it later and everybody uses uh
rodney or lewis black as the example
right guys that made it after the 40s
every time yeah and uh and neil's like
right so
uh you're either louis black this
amazing writer or you're
rodney a living cartoon character
he really is rover dangerfield was like
less of a cartoon
rodney as a cartoon dog was like less
right yeah that was more rodney in real
life more subtle more tame
but also you know when you think about
the energy that he had behind it and all
and then you know it was the era of coke
like people were doing a lot when you
think of how hard we work and it's like
of course like show business fueled on
coke it's like they were cheating you
know
we're doing all this straight like with
no like just down in coffee and trying
to keep going like with espresso and
stuff right rodney was doing rails and
then going on to the troops you know
what i'm talking about it is the steroid
error for comedy yeah right
like barry bonds you're like yeah it's
easy to hit 73
when you're yolked out of your [ __ ]
not easy but like you got an advantage
also a testament how funny is because
comedy got really cool then it was like
carlin with the beard and pryor was
[ __ ] awesome man you know robin
williams was fun as hell and all over
the room but rodney was just in the
pocket suit on red tie
but relentless relentless jokes though
like there was no it was it was going to
be by submission you were yes he's just
going to keep coming you ever have those
times when you're in trouble like at a
corporate gig or some kind of weird room
and you're like
it's just like you know you're in you're
you're in trouble yeah this could go
either way and you just say
[ __ ] it i'm just relying just rely on
the act just right
just
pull it in tight yeah and just keep it
go and then slowly you start to gain
control just from the material yes yes
that's what rodney lived by that's true
but he never lost him that's the only
difference
he walks out you're laughing like what
is this
you're one of the smoothest at that i
mean i i think about like you do believe
in your material in a way like you have
such polish i remember watching you once
you hosted the greg geraldo benefit at
the beginning yeah i remember that gig
and it was a kind of a hell spot you
hosted it people are still walking in
and i was kind of like oh [ __ ] i know
tom pop is a killer but this is a this
is like i'm nervous yeah because this is
so bad and you just slowly start
crushing oh really and you weren't doing
any tricks you were just kind of doing
your act no just hang on it yeah because
once you because that's so you that's
what you got and it's like to start
calling audibles and jumping into
especially in a room that big
where you know there's no like crowd
work or other ways to get out of it yeah
it's just just believe in it slow down
and just you know the stuff's there you
know you've got it you know it's gonna
it's solid yeah
i used to hear those horror stories like
back in the day the comedy seller would
have four people in it and even if it
was empty you'd have to do your act in
case someone walked in so they would see
you doing comedy and sit down and so you
acted to be so good that people could
just slide into it randomly and that's
kind of what you're saying you just have
to
be so good that people will just glom on
you slowly right well you both work that
way you guys are living on your material
there's not oh yeah there's not you real
faith in it and yeah well written jokes
you know you've got really well written
stuff so but don't you get annoyed and
frustrated when you're like ah now
you're on board but you missed some gold
back there but i guess it's like
soldiers we have to like lose them early
in the war
to keep going
you're a dude i'll listen to sometimes
just like i'll listen to an album
because you're so we're very different
but you're a joke guy so you know you're
doing bits about your family and stuff
but you do family material in a way
that's so
it just kind of works for anyone i think
it's so i love your family mature i love
your bits about your kids why do you
think that is why do you think it works
for like 18 year olds at the laugh
factory and because it's so it's just so
honest like you paint a picture in a way
that's just funny like you do a thing
that burr does where like
burr does this too like he'll just say
the image and it's in your head and
you're just laughing like you've a bit
about i think about a few you you've
been mentioned on this pod a lot but
there's a bit i think about of uh you
know you talking about having uh uh i
quote this bit all the way well you have
three daughters right
two daughters and a wife and you're like
yeah i always dreamed of living in a
house with three people who hate
everything i love
and then you yeah see like just me
retelling his bit is getting laughing
here
and then you do the whole act out of
like you know
you're sharing the bathroom they're
putting their hand under the door
there's no escape then there's the cat's
paw that's under the door too like you
paint a picture and i'm like this is
either happened or it's basically
happened right yeah yeah it totally
happened yeah i thought you're gonna say
the other one this i saw you do this at
bananas i opened for you i don't know
what was that 2009 or some [ __ ] didn't i
drive you out there with my wife in a
minivan
mate we went out two nights first night
was me and you second night i think she
was there yeah i remember when mark was
opening for you i was like holy [ __ ]
you're opening for tom i was blowing
bananas
[Laughter]
you're opening the you're opening the
side room of a marriott off a highway
yeah couldn't wait it was like carney
hall back then to me i was ready yeah
but you had a bit where you said uh oh i
still think about it you go people are
like oh my god you got a beautiful wife
you got kids how how how do you do it
you go on the road all the time like how
do you leave them it must be so hard and
go well the hardest part is try not to
whistle while i pack
come on
it doesn't get any better than that
that's gold that is
such a great whistle that's a joke that
you just get i mean it's just like
that's i think the thing is you just
make it
you just make it feel so real so it's
just i i think that's why it's
impossible right i mean don't you feel
that you connect with younger audiences
yeah other audiences no i i always kind
of i don't know like the why of it but i
i always feel like
you don't have to be the head of the
family to you just have to have been a
part of a family right
right like you just have to have been a
kid or a
daughter or son or wife like we've all
know these from all these different
angles and i do try and express it like
from the kid you know like now i have
this other this
this newer joke that's like coming from
the kids angle so yeah i think it's just
unless you're an orphan who never
was raised by anybody you should be able
to get the jokes yeah because even a
wife can hear that whistle while i pack
joke and be like i get it i want to
leave too yeah right you know so it hits
everybody yeah and as as
sorry but as a younger
audience member or fan like uh just you
don't you don't make it like
it has to be like super you know you
have to be there like you have to be a
part of it it's relatable either way
because you're never like
you know these kids am i right you know
whatever but like you just like you said
you paint the picture like and it's like
relatable either way from anything right
perspective oh yeah that's great i agree
yeah you're not you're not like it's not
like oh my old ball and chain it's not
that type of material you're saying in
like a different type of way right
there's more vulnerability to it where
you're like i'm like almost a prisoner
in my own house
right so i gotta ask like as a guy
who started in that era i mean it was
patrice it was bill burr it was norton
it was apollo these are like
dudes angry
maybe a little uh maybe they'll throw
some misogyny just peppered on top
whereas you're like a nice guy married
guy was that tough kind of navigating
through those
ball busters because you but you are
friends with those dudes as well yeah
and we like them as well yeah no i'm
geraldo is like my best friend in comedy
but gaffigan was also a really good
friend oh yeah and he was kind of off in
his own thing
uh it was hard in the very beginning
when i first like came to the cellar
um
and
uh even the before well before that like
at the comic strip it was a little
difficult because i sh that's where i
first showed up
and
i was very i was more actory out i would
like i was broad i was like you know i
didn't have much you know i was just
showing up literally yeah so i would act
things out a little bit more but i would
kill like i would do really well and
that didn't go well with the guys that
were not like the guys even the class
ahead like the
um like the louise and the kevin
brennans and all that um
they saw me like as not as a real comic
but i was killing
and you know what i mean and i did like
there was a moment where i was like
should i try to kill less like yeah yeah
which is such a messed up place to be as
a comedian it's like they do to you yeah
but that's what they do to you i was
like should i just be like kind of
like backing it off
uh but i couldn't i was like it was the
only thing and i knew what they were
saying like i knew what the impression
like i was i was just i was trying i
didn't have the material
to just stand at the mic like i needed
to kind of act it out a little bit more
and right and do that kind of a thing
well those dudes are like a guy like
louie's probably working on like a new
hour or something he's trying to like at
that point well it was before that it
was even it was earlier than that and uh
yeah he was just uh mean he was just wow
he was a straight out mean damn are you
guys cool now or no yeah like i don't
really see him that much but you know he
was friendlier later on um but yeah back
then he was
he was kind of a dick what do you think
that what do you think it was do you
think it was i don't know he was he
hadn't been he didn't become he wasn't
louis yet you know what i mean and so
maybe those guys were kind of relentless
of like you know really believing their
way was the right way or whatever and
then you have a guy
a fresh-faced guy who's up there like
you know acting stuff out a little bit
more and not like of the new york
pedigree like of that thing yeah
and uh going up like you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah
which is totally cool but you don't have
to go up to a young comic and be like i
don't like you
wow
you know what i mean i am it was that
aggressive damn and uh
and i just kind of played it off i was
like so we'll be best friends
[Laughter]
well it's weird because we all follow
comics that we don't like following at
times but it's also kind of like it's
new york man figure it out right no i i
think like that's the challenge too and
you know we're all trying to work on new
hours and you know the seller can be a
tough place to work on that new [ __ ]
because you're following some young
comic who's bringing the heat right and
i'm doing new [ __ ] yeah and i'm and i'm
like wow i i you know i got buried a
little bit by some young killer there
yeah you know you're following someone
like damn daniel simonson or sam jay who
murdered the other night right you know
there's people just straight up
murdering and i'm like yeah this is my
freshest 15 i have yeah and you picture
the audience leaving going ah that tall
uh lanky kind of ugly guy
yeah
i don't know why
you know you picture them going home
like he wasn't that good you're like no
i can do it i just saw a new stuff night
yeah that kills me and you know
like so maybe it's that vulnerability
like of those guys at the time
and you just kind of like you know they
want you you know like we all when you
show up it's
they don't you don't just get to sit at
the table like there's an initiation a
quiet it's not said but you got to kind
of win your way some one of the one of
the one of the crew has to think
you're good yeah and then they kind of
like all of a sudden just like welcome
you in who is the first of the crew who
welcomed you in
um
probably i don't know like kevin brennan
like kevin brennan was like it was a
brennan
attel
de paulo
you know patrice was just emerging but
those guys were like the
juniors yeah like we and then it was we
were all that next kind of class so
those guys i mean i remember being at
boston comedy club and waiting to go on
it was like this monday night they had
this amazing monday night thing where
you had to go and like beg to get on and
regulars would come in this small place
and it was like this it was really like
a a hornet's nest yeah and it was
intense and great and just seeing kevin
brandon like walk in in a trench coat
you know like just walking to the back
in the shotgun oh [ __ ] he's he's here
you know what i mean yeah and he was he
was like he wasn't off the rails mean he
was just old kevin mean you know right
right and uh
and it wasn't you know and then a towel
just like you know and
and you think back like they were just
finding their way it's like when you
think of like your dad like when you
picture like oh he was my age right when
he did that like when you think of like
kevin he was a kid too and he was it was
a lot of bravado in china they were the
guys and finding their way and doing
their thing
and
i'm all i'm all for you have to chip
away and and find your way in yeah um
louie was the only one that like
outright
right up to me just like gave me [ __ ]
and not [ __ ] like hey you're doing this
like i remember these two comics in la
what um
like i'll mention them off the air but
uh and the one guy was crushing and came
off and the other comic was like
you know if you had really good mate if
you actually had material you'd be
amazing
and it was a total douche thing to say
and the guy did not take it well but the
guy critiquing him was like trying to
say you're amazing but you need to just
focus on the jokes and you'll [ __ ]
you'll be unstoppable
it's almost like a basketball player
just like doing [ __ ] ball handling
[ __ ] and it's like take a shot dude
shoot the [ __ ] ball yeah yeah i know
what he's saying i get that but yeah so
it's like a slow creep like kevin was
like one of the first guys who just
would like you know start talking to you
in the hall it's like you know that kind
of thing and then a towel took a while
how dark were things that kevin brennan
was a little warm guy
yeah right exactly it was pretty rough
and it wasn't like it was because like
seller didn't have crowds and you know
that boston was like this rough place
and you comic strip would be great on
the weekends and it was like comedy had
fallen on its ass yeah when we showed up
so it was like kind of this new kind of
frontier in a way and everybody was just
kind of
scrambling so they so it was a little
difficult for them but then going to the
seller for the first time like back to
your original question of like how all
those killers mean killers you know
patrice and all of our guys
uh
i did have a feeling like when i first
got there like i was following a tell
every night like oh she just kept
putting me after a towel and i was like
well i guess i've gotta like i don't
know lean against the wall or like get a
cigarette like how am i gonna i gotta be
i gotta try and be i was cursing more
like i don't really curse in my life but
i was like right you [ __ ] my and the
audience was like what are you doing
like you didn't even know me but you
could tell like what are you what are
you doing yeah yeah and it wasn't until
i really just put the blinders on
and didn't watch him or didn't watch
anybody and just waited in isolation
until my spot that i could
calm down that's good advice and not
start the influence was too great of all
of this stuff
so i was just like just go be
alone and then i could be out there so
then i could walk up and just be myself
not knowing what happened before me just
do my thing and not think of like where
it fit like i wasn't it didn't matter
that patrice or
bill burr or whatever was geraldo was
going on because i didn't really know
what they were doing that's good and i
was just doing my thing and then it
slowly emerged like
tom's getting up there talking about his
his girlfriend yeah you know and and it
wasn't like it had to come from the
outside uh-huh what about how did your
friendship with greg start
he was the first person i first comedian
i ever saw i walked into
on june 12th 1993
i
had a bringer show at the um at the new
york comedy club which was upstairs from
this like cowboy bar it was like five in
the afternoon so it was like light out
in the summer and uh i just called her
from my apartment in new jersey and got
the date
and uh
and brought my friends in and walked in
and the only other guy on the show
because it was five o'clock
uh was greg
greg was just sitting there waiting pale
face no beard sweating
scared out of his mind just like shaking
like how's it going man i'm good good
and i'm just equally as freaked out yeah
and we just started talking and
we both like liked each other
immediately and we went up into this you
know half-assed show was my first set of
my life wow and uh and uh we exchanged
numbers quickly and that was it that was
it i knew then that like i was going to
be a comedian that was it that was all
sewn up after that horrible five minutes
yep and then uh
and i knew that
you know i'm gonna and i have to attach
myself to this guy yeah because uh
he thinks i'm funny i think he's funny
and this is gonna be gonna be okay was
it wild what because he he came up
pretty quick i mean he just had it he
was just gifted yeah
but i guess you guys
stayed together we did toe to toe
so that must have been fun coming up
with a friend like going through the
ranks 10 tv it was like him and gaffigan
and myself at least like in the new york
scene
we all quickly
were hosting shows like all that bringer
stuff you know we quickly just emerged
and started getting hosting stuff we're
like moving out of the bringer stuff and
letting us
get a spot and you know
we all the three of us moved quickly and
the one who was the biggest doubt was
gaffigan really because
because he was sticking to his thing
and greg and i were like i was really
loud and moving around like crazy and
greg actually told me you know you don't
have to lunge when you tell jokes
you could just tell them like you've got
stuff just do it and i was like oh okay
and uh and greg would kill did you
bounce bits with greg a lot yeah
you like workshop stuff uh no but you'd
be like oh we tack stuff in we never
like sat and wrote together
that kind of thing but gaffigan would
just be like
we greg would kill i would kill loud
blah blah blah you know it's all pure
energy and fear and then uh and gaffing
would get up and just start pacing on
this stage like oh you you're perfect
oh why is she saying that what you doing
here and we're like
you guys got to get it together
like that guy is just he's he's going
down he doesn't does he know he's
bombing like wow and he just stuck to it
he just stuck to his style and just
stuck to it and then of course wow
started crushing with that yeah the rest
is history
yeah but we all rose like quickly like
you guys like from what i could tell
from the outside like you would you guys
and joe and like you just kind of like
you were at the same
pacing yeah having friends like that
like you had greg and jim i mean having
mark and joe list yeah the other people
in our crew is like we had such a we had
such a crazy talented crew like yeah i
watched mark and list and you know all
the people phil hanley all these seller
comics you know i'm just like damn he's
got another new bit that's so funny you
know we're talking about how like phil
just would [ __ ] on us off stage in a way
that made us laugh
like having friends like that where
you're like oh [ __ ] it makes you want to
be
just funnier it just makes you want your
act you're like i got to put more work
into my act yeah i know and then
yeah and i had this thing where
the girl i was with um
her
her father passed away and
and uh i had to kind of like take care
of her and i dropped comedy
like a year in you're like [ __ ] i got to
miss a weekend of bananas yeah i wasn't
even doing bananas yet like it was just
it was just city spots i don't even know
if i had a road gig yet
and
it was that it was that early like a
year you know like when you're doing
like one spot every two weeks kind of a
thing and
and um so anyway i i just started
working and i just felt like i had to
take care of her and not
do comedy i'm like you know it was all
[ __ ] up like
she i gotta get a job and
make some money and replace her dad yeah
and geraldo called me every single day i
worked in a little ad agency and he
called me every day what are you doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing let's go
what are you what are you doing you got
to come back what do you do no i know i
just need you know if i if i just need
to make some money we'll [ __ ] make
money let's go any just
every day wow and that's that that's
like the real personification of what
you're saying it's like
you encouraged each other you're like
even [ __ ] around you're like you're
pulling each other and pushing each
other yeah at the same time and when
you're that new those those days are
essential you need everything
every spot you can't take a week off
you'll fall behind they'll help they'll
get higher than you so it's
yeah [ __ ] that girl's dad i'm glad
[Laughter]
he was a [ __ ] block for comedy yeah
but you know mark was another one where
like he was so hardcore i mean
it's funny when you started stand up you
kind of are with your friends you kind
of go your own way for a while because
you have to you have to go your own way
but you stay in touch you you know but i
have friends who like i started with and
then you just kind of don't see them for
a while because they're working the door
somewhere you're walking the door
somewhere then you
uh
you come back together
and it's like a moment hasn't even
passed yeah and you have that weird
friendship but yeah yeah mark was so
hardcore i remember mike lawrence was
saying oh
yeah i mean mike if you don't know mike
i love mike i used i yeah mike opened
for me a couple times and then i
he wrote on a couple things that i was
doing i just that guy was brilliant he's
a machine she's like a savant yeah he
really is he really is and he's just uh
you know but he was a dude when i was
like holy [ __ ] this guy to open mike's
is terrifying yeah
whoever he goes up after he's they're
getting torn to shreds yeah yeah i'm
like you wasted your two and a half
minutes just ruining a guy's night
but then you know but then mike starts
getting success he becomes like you know
he's chilled out chilled out right and
he's such a good
writer like he was so fun to be around
and so fast guys like dan st jermaine we
started with like comics you were like
so funny and you yeah
pushing through
and
i always tell you on comics you're like
what's your advice i'm like surround
yourself with driven funny people yeah
it will change your life that's perfect
if they're motivated but not annoying
yeah right right i was thinking about
that today because i had to go to uh
bobby's studio to do a bunch of stuff
bobby kelly yeah
and uh
and i'm walking
i'm walking down third and crossing
mcdougall like in the middle of the
street it's just that quiet morning
village thing you know like
and you know when i lived here forever
it was like and i just as a and i guess
i had you guys on my mind as i was like
crossing and i was like this it just
brought me back to when
i was like so excited yes could see the
seller i was so comfortable enough to
like go sit at the cellar during the day
yeah that kind of thing and it really is
like we all had our packs and our
moments and i know you guys had like
your time was the time and my time yes
and now that these
guys i don't know who are there and
they're emerging and they're going to
build that same thing right so good it's
so great and it's good when you see new
guys who are you know and they're just
crushing and you're excited for them
because you're like oh my god yeah i
want to know how cool this is or you see
i'll see like young comics bouncing bits
and i get like happy i'm like oh my god
yeah yeah they're hungry who is the uh
who's the kid i think he's from atlanta
oh mike rowland yeah very short guy
really funny yeah yeah pretty short guy
yeah he's funny yeah i really liked him
and and i
you know i we i think of everybody as
the same age i just think everybody's
like from colin to that guy we're all
kind of like just yeah we're not back
far off in years or whatever and i just
like complimented him and he was like
bugging out
and i was like oh right like i forget
like this would be like you know depaolo
saying holy [ __ ] you can really tell
jokes i would have been like riding that
for like two weeks yeah you know what i
mean exactly yeah it's really impressive
really okay
ask her something could i have a another
martini but just do it without the juice
just do it straight up clean you know
what and i'm going to drop these olives
into it no problem and i'm going to join
them but with new olives
absolutely sweet thank you this is nice
having a bartender oh my god
dude uh colin quinn uh is a guy like we
talk about colin a lot on here you get a
lot your name gets mentioned a lot we've
quoted your bits a lot i feel like
that's good but you know uh
so you and greg were tight i mean that's
like
greg the guy we talk about so much in
here because you know we all know he was
brilliant i feel like he should have
been a bigger comic you know
obviously he passed away so young i mean
like
i remember you in the documentary is
that like is that insane to just be in a
documentary like this guy
should have been one of the biggest
comics ever yeah it was yeah he would
have been the timing of it if he had
if he had stayed straight yeah if he had
handled that
he would have um
i think he would have taken the daily
show after john whoa wow i felt like
because you know comedy central loved
him comedy central
smart as a whip yeah a latin voice ah
columbia good crossover he never played
that up and i think that in a way hurt
maybe with the industry not with
comments with us a little bit but i
think like it also the times were he
didn't do it in a time when it was kind
of
it wasn't emerging like as a cultural
phenomenon right you know i mean like
they weren't they didn't in a way have
like that cultural place yet i just felt
like the time he was going to be and the
stuff he talked about it was all very
political and like today it wasn't like
you know evergreen it was i'm i'm going
after all the [ __ ] we were dealing with
right now yes i just felt like he was
our he was going to be our
bill maher or john stewart wow material
wise poise wise and then his in his uh
in his hispanic way
like he was i felt like that was going
to be his path that was going to be the
thing that he deserved it he would have
done he deserved it he really could have
done it because he was as quick as a
whip he was hyper intelligent oh yeah
for the folks at home he was he went to
columbia college i think he was a
valedictorian or whatever you call it
then he went to harvard law right and
then he was you know top of his class in
that and then he became a lawyer and
then he just gave it up yeah to be a
comedian yeah that's when i met him i
mean he really was and he went to saint
regis
high school
yeah he was a uh
he was a master at social commentary
it's like when guys like that die you're
just like
selfishly as a comedy fan you're like i
want to hear what you would have said
about trump and biden i know i want to
hear what you would the vaccine
all that who else patrice the same
thing he would love the same
[Laughter]
yeah can i ask you about seinfeld
because i know like you know you tour
with jerry a lot and
uh i mean
you used to yeah yeah but how did that i
know i know you do your own thing for a
long time but like yeah how did that
start
um new york uh stand-up new york i was
at stand-up new york
after he did his show
he was coming back poking around in the
clubs he wasn't doing sets yet he was
just checking out the scene and he was
just kind of coming and hanging out and
watching stuff
and two nights in a row you know at new
york at stanford new york you could see
through the window to the bar and two
nights in a row you walked in while i
was on stage wow is he shooting the
documentary or yeah okay this is like a
year
while you're on there yeah i saw him
like you know watching through the
through the thing
and uh god when i saw him come in the
next night like the second night i
quickly abandoned what i was working on
and showed him other stuff
you're looking at your notepad what else
all right here's my closer yeah play the
hits yeah
and i came off stage and he took me
aside and he's like you're really funny
you're really funny and i was just like
ah
right it's like wayne gretzky coming up
after hockey practice and
and uh how long in were you
um that was 90
that was like 97.
thank you 98. thank you when the show
ended the show uh
show ended in 1998. so you were his show
in 98. thank you yeah because i had met
my i met cynthia
uh at like in 98 and then his thing so
99 i guess is when i met him do you know
you got the show
98
oh you have it up there look at you
sorry i don't know if this is your job i
just saw it last night yeah
he's all over it oh 98 you're right 98.
yeah so that was may of 98. so i either
met him like the end of 98.
i think he took a year off so i'd call
it 99.
99. so i'm six years in six years in
that's nothing yeah it's not that's
pretty new it is pretty new but he was
very cool to you he was super cool and
you know we kind of like had the same
sense of humor and you know and i it was
a it was uh it was the greatest gift to
me as a comedian like when people asked
like what your break is it was meeting
him
because
he once people said like once he like
endorsed me
like people started paying a little more
attention
and
but more than that just being around
like when you talk about all the angry
guys at the cellar yeah
like i didn't write i didn't work like
that i didn't get go out and drink at
the end of the night right i was i
wanted to sit with my pad in the day and
work on my jokes and go do my thing and
then maybe go get something to eat with
my girlfriend and go home
you know drink a little bit and hang
late at the cellar but i wasn't like
getting high and
and i was like i was longing for an
example and then he came in and he's
like
yeah you get your pad and you go to work
in the day
and then you go do your set you go home
and you work on it some more and that's
how you do it and it was like a
confirmation that
my way it was that my way was away yeah
you know what i mean like kudos for you
for not conforming and just being like
well just become an angry guy on stage
like you stuck to who you are yeah well
there's no choice you know
yeah but that really confirms so i just
soaked everything in
that i could he was just like a
just the way he carried himself off
stage the way you just treat the
greatest i call him the comedy
chiropractor like anytime i'd feel
[ __ ] up about
my set or my place in the business or
whatever any kind of funky we all get
one call with him
and he just made you realize
we are the luckiest people in the world
to be a stand-up comedian and be in a
world of standard you would hang up
every phone call i didn't even have to
talk about my [ __ ] i would just talk
with him and he'd throw out bits and
we'd just [ __ ] and make each other
laugh and i would hang up and be like oh
everything's okay
everything's everything's all right you
know he just had such a love
for it and such a respect for it and he
can tell when you do and that means the
world to him that's why i think he he
gloms on to people who also have that
love that he has i have to go back just
because it's been in my head since we
did it that uh that line that you said
back at bananas about uh whistle while
you've hacked yes
jerry and i had a disagreement about
whose line that was uh oh
yeah
and
i
could swear like it was my line not even
a stand-up line and that when we would
go on the road and we'd like he'd send
the car to get me and then they would
pick him up and then go and then when i
did the line on a show
and he was like that's my line oh and i
was like i don't think so i think it's
my line and i really truly was one of
those things like no one's out to [ __ ]
each other this is just like two comics
like
you know who are so connected and
together yeah you know eight years of
almost every weekend
and it's just this gray area
but he's jerry seinfeld so i give him
that line oh
no
yeah i gotta kind of i gotta kind of
give it to him
i didn't record it pay it forward but i
do feel like
you know
that's weird it was yeah it was one of
those
special views no
wow damn i thought it was
the mandela effect damn yeah
do you ever want to see him and go hey
how about that has a pack line doing
yeah well you know because it's been out
there and people do bring it up every
once in a while oh and a coupe class
thank you wow that's wild yeah it's a
little bit of a this strange area if
seinfeld ever said that to me like
that's my line i'd get that pit in my
stomach like oh [ __ ] did i steal from
you but it's hard you could just pause
say joey you don't have enough
yeah
but he's such you know i don't know i
mean look just out of respect it's like
of course no he's a legend yeah i'm
[ __ ] not given to you but i would but
it's such a great line and i really
thought i was mine and
uh
so yeah but i can't but i see that
you're cut from the same cloth as jerry
and i and i get that i mean you you're
an old-school comic the way jerry is
like very inspired by robert klein i see
like you you're a dude that could have
been like a tonight show guy in the 70s
or 80s yeah oh yeah i i think we think
we mention your jokes all the time
because you have great drinking jokes
too i mean i think of the how does one
go where you're uh you talk about like
drinking over the sink you know what i'm
talking about yeah um how is that uh
i've been i've been drinking a lot more
since since i had a family i think uh
i've been drinking a lot more and not
that fun happy hour woo-woo kind of
drinking it's more like standing alone
at the kitchen sink kind of drink
it's so so relatable yeah yeah god bless
america and god bless sheath underwear
mark's wearing them right now i'm i'm
saving them for the weekend sheath
underwear keeps your balls off your leg
it's hot as hell out there the idea for
sheath came from its founder us army
soldier robert padden during his second
tour in iraq this is this is a real
patriot here and a nice guy
if it worked for him it'll work for you
i wear sheath underwear they're great
you do too oh yeah i look forward to
wearing them there's you you know
there's your pears you're like and then
there's your sheath and you're like yeah
i'm gonna look true support the show
support this awesome veteran-owned
company go to sheathunderwear.com use
promo code drunk and get 20 off your
first order
every order comes with sheath 100 money
back guarantee that sheath underwear dot
com promo code drunk get sheath
underwear and let them support your ball
bag hell yeah
looking for something different to cover
up that hole in your wall disc plate is
that cool new metal poster that you'll
want in every room they have millions of
cool designs available featuring gaming
movies comics and anime displayed also
features officially licensed designs
including star wars netflix and many
more uh lots of cool stuff you can get
on this site it only takes 20 seconds to
hang a display no power tools needed no
damages
no frustrations you know i'm a very
irritable person i have no housing
skills so this comes in handy once you
mount one you can switch out a new plate
and a flash with everyone that you buy
disc plate plants a tree
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorite displays and save
up to
29
get 25 percent off when you buy one or
two and 29 off when you buy three or
more discounts will automatically be
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use code drunk when you visit
display.com that's display.com code
drunk or click that link in our show
notes okay no matter how hot it gets
outside keep your bong ice cold just
freeze it pack it and rip it the hot
smoke passes through the frozen piece
cooling down your smoke as you inhale
your smoke so cold they'll be calling
you chilly willy
i love this bubbler i mean why this
takes so long to get invented my friends
used to put ice in the middle of their
bong it never worked it didn't it didn't
help this is way better they perfected
it they nailed it
don't have that hot throat that sting
forget it those are from the past the
frozen beer mug but for smokers perfect
way to put it freeze pipe is non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
frozen longer freeze pipe cools down the
smoke by hundreds of degrees
freeze pipe is taking care of the bozos
go to thefreezepipe.com
use code drunk to save 10 off your first
order get yourself a new bong pipe or
bubbler today that's the th e
freezepipe.com
code drunk to save 10
freeze pipe keeping it cool while you're
high as a kite
all right so you said um
you said uh if there's any jokes that
i'm working on we we welcome it oh you
do you got a newbie uh yeah it's a
pretty much a newbie and i i did colin's
spot last night at the pussycat because
he wasn't around so i ran my
longer set
and uh i'm really hesitating from saying
the hour i think there's a there's a
disease in comedy that we're all working
on the hour doing the hour everyone's
working on the new hour if you have your
hour are you doing your hour
i don't even save the youtube anymore
yeah that's all i'm like what's
how are we all lemmings all of a sudden
like can we just i'm doing i'm working
on my new um comedy film yeah and uh
and it doesn't really fit in the act
because it's new and there's no place
for it yeah but um
uh
it's a joke
about uh
how there's um there's no rules anymore
like we can might we can do whatever we
want now that everything's collapsing
there's no real rules we kind of like we
need some new ways of of doing things
and
five billionaires have all the money
now
uh we have all these problems only five
guys have the money
let's let's kidnap some billionaires
right let's why not let's go after let's
go after some billionaires yeah they're
out there they've got they've got the
money you can be a billionaire i'm all
for it i'm all for you achieving and
changing the world great you're a
billionaire you get to be a billionaire
for 24 hours ah and then if you don't
start giving that [ __ ] away by morning
right and helping some people out we're
coming to get you
and there's a guy in my kid there's a
guy at my kid's school who needs a leg
he needs a new leg and not even a real
leg a fake leg this guy needs a fake leg
i don't know what a fake leg costs like
a starter kit leg is like 50 grand 30
grand and they can't afford it so what's
their what do all these people all their
resources what can they come up with a
bake sale yay
let's have a bake sale let's make
snickerdoodles and sell them for 50
cents a piece right yay should we charge
a dollar no that would be greedy
at the end of the day in the hot sun
selling snickerdoodles they make
37.50
if they have 700 more bake sales mr
johnson's still
hopping around town i like it i love it
it's
it's super timely too because the
billionaires the bezos is the musk we
they don't give the money to us but they
have all of it and we're the ones who
need the money so what if it's what if
an angle could be
billionaires of the new santa you know
like i need a new leg
dear mr mr musk you know and you send
him to the wish list instead of santa he
just started like in a it's a
miracle on 34th street where they just
start dumping letters on his desk
and then on christmas day we can sit on
his lap you know i want to see bezos in
like an actual uh blowtorch uh sled it's
electric and just floating through the
air
dumping [ __ ] yeah he could totally do
that the blue origin sled right right
i love the idea that they've like yeah
you're already a billionaire you've got
the head start hire some [ __ ] dope
security oh you're going down yeah yeah
it's like hunger games right it's like
we used to evade iraq now we invaded uh
bezos's compound right
we need oil yeah and how are you gonna
stop all of us if we all come after you
if it was
the front line might get it but some of
us are getting over that wall yeah maybe
that's why musk is boring because he's
like when they come for me i'm ready to
get out
well this is america you can achieve
your dreams to a point
yeah
then we'll come back get greedy [ __ ] the
irs we're gonna knock you down [ __ ] the
irs watch over the u.s we're coming at
ya that's i mean it's it's really funny
it could be i you know our [ __ ] is
usually way worse that we really usually
we run way looser i feel like my shit's
either working or it's [ __ ] terrible
that's my [ __ ] yeah usually i feel like
uh
i'm a little leery of uh billionaires
because i know
but it should be at the same time
it's like it's you should run this bible
late night
[Laughter]
you ever want to work with me again
i'll kill you you piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you in the pop-tart movie
i'm not uh are you not i'm not either i
thought it was some kind of message yeah
it is a message
it is a message because i know a couple
of comics who are in it i'm like that
guy's in it
i heard some comics whistling all the
way to that movie
he wrote that
gaffigan came uh
came over for dinner because he's in la
and uh i invited him over for dinner
uh a couple sundays ago
oh can you make your own but
and he came in and uh
he immediately like wanted to defuse the
obvious like elephant in the room which
is um why aren't you in the movie i feel
like it should be it's in the 1950s like
guys making pop tarts it should be you
and ryan hamilton and me all running
through the hallway yeah like yeah it
should be
well you're such an old school
movie guy you're in the informant with
matt oh my god that's right what was
that experience like amazing i mean that
was the thing like the coolest [ __ ]
the coolest guy he's been at the seller
a few times yeah he's the coolest guy
he's exactly like he would not
disappoint in any hopefulness you have
for him being like a good guy you could
hang with loves comedy really him and
ben used to when they first came to la
they would just go to the improv they
had no friends they didn't know you know
they were making their way and they
would come sit in the improv which you
know didn't have much of a crowd at the
time um
excuse me and uh they would just watch
comedian they watched like alan hayvey
we want because he's i think the oldest
guy we can get on here who would still
drink
yeah true yeah
he's a hilarious if you guys don't know
ellen havey youtube has led him and said
oh yeah i mean you might know him as lou
avery from mad men
yeah he's a good actor he's kind of
stuff and that's a really good actor he
was in the informant with me oh yeah
yeah
he was um billions he's done a lot of
stuff yeah he's really good
and do you ever see his talk show i've
heard of it i've never seen this i know
yeah so good it was on ha
which was the original it was like the
origin was like the comedy channel and
ha and they merged and became comedy
central right
the way it went down i think so and i
was just out of college
and i wasn't a comic yet hadn't done a
set yet and i would watch him
do this like late night weird talk show
he had the audience of one where it was
just one person that would write in and
they'd put a little um velvet rope
around them and they would be the
audience member for the show
and he would do great bits he was really
smooth and funny yeah he was cool he had
loud and wayne right
and then i got to meet him like that was
like a quick lesson in comedy that you
can get to your idols really fast yes
you don't have to like get parts and
really just like walk in and they're
going to be there right in the back
yeah it was pretty great you were saying
something um i was talking about alan
havey and the informant oh the informant
yes
matt is a was a huge comedy fan and uh
so he's such a cool like he's always
thinking jokes and just hanging around
all that kind of stuff and
i got that was the first film i did with
them and i auditioned and i think i got
it because i look like uh the guy it was
a real story oh okay and um the first
scene
it was at this house
matt knew you were a comic matt knew i
was a comic
and uh
like
the scene was i come out of the he
he
i come out of the house and he's talking
to me he's in trouble i'm his boss and
then a car pulls up and we do the scene
in the in the headlights of this car
and
uh we we kind of like meet for the first
time and someone's making noise and matt
starts quoting i might start quoting uh
tom waits yeah he's like what's he
building in there
what's you know that song by tom wait
what's he building there it's just like
this abstract song so i'm like all right
stu's quoting tom waits right off the
bat all right this is gonna be cool so
then we go to run it and i come out and
matt's like i'm playing and i'm all
freaked out we do this
thing and they're like um or you want it
you want to run it again and the car
comes up and they go you want to run it
again
and they're like okay so we go to do it
again and i'm thinking we're still in
rehearsal
and uh
they're like all right that's good yep
moving on and i'm like
i i thought we were just rehearsed and
you don't want to act like you don't
know what how movies work yeah yeah so i
got someone on the side i'm like
what what's up i didn't even see
sodeberg like where's soderberg i'd met
him earlier but where's he didn't even
there's no cameras here what do you mean
wow we're moving on soderberg is in the
car
that pulls up what in the back seat
holding his own camera between his legs
and shooting the scene that way wow
[Music]
he clocked us twice i thought we were
rehearsing we were just doing it and
they and he did that on purpose and i
don't think he did it to i don't i think
he was thinking probably more about holy
[ __ ] his camera position and stuff and
he probably assumed
that i know
they probably said a word yeah an act
like that meant like this is for real
you worked with him a couple of times
you did the liberace so yeah so then i
worked on um i did the liberace movie
with him
and the nick
damn and
mike douglas
the coolest really oh my god just hear
that voice yeah and you're in the same
room as that voice you're like oh god
tried to take that voice away just
because of catherine zeta-jones sweet
vagina how dare you
how dare he yes don't you ever deprive
us of that sweet michael douglas
what a good husband
what an icon he is he is an icon he was
always he was dressed as he was dressed
as
as liberace and like this really
flamboyant like giant thing and i played
like the camera between his legs
and i played his tour manager and we're
not we're not miked we're just off on
the side it's matt's scene with whoever
and uh
and they're running it and
michael and i are
just making pretend small talk in the
background of the movie and he's like
yes how's it going yeah are we going to
go tour and yeah
and soderbergh is like two three takes
and you move on like he's quick he knows
what he wants and this one's going like
four five six takes of the scene and at
some point
uh he turns to me goes in the liberace
voice he's like
man he's really doing a lot of takes i
really gotta take a dump
oh wow
[Music]
michael douglas yeah he's like holy [ __ ]
he is holly what's like what's like the
best michael douglas movie ever fatal
attraction wall street basically wall
street oh yeah that was hot sexy what
about uh wall street's badass yeah wall
street gecko my god is it a movie called
the game which is the game is great
great movie david fincher yeah
what's his face sean penn's in that
uh yeah that's great so
any and he produced cuckoo's nest is
that right yeah he produced cuckoo's
nest and his box
wow he was roommates with uh danny
devito at the time i think oh
no yeah cuckoo's nest is [ __ ]
incredible oh disclosure that was a hot
one he was like the hot guy he was like
the guy who [ __ ] romance and the stone
yes
there's a great i wonder if we could
find
there's an uh
tonight's show with him danny devito
uh-huh in romancing the stone and who is
the woman and kathleen turner yeah and
the three of them are out there
hammered smoking scars and just trashed
and there's a lot of innuendo of like
what went on
i like that and the three of them are
just
kathleen turner man she was something
body heat remember that [ __ ] do i know
body heat and body that's a classic so i
lost my hymen
oh wait can you tell the steve martin
story
wait but do you think do you think that
uh
do you think that um
the billionaire thing is worth working
working on yeah yeah really we were
laughing 18 tags on that yeah that's
definitely good that's a great idea it's
a real premise you should hear the horse
[ __ ] we're throwing out yeah
what do you got what's the deal with
cucumbers i mean i'm embarrassed to
break out whatever [ __ ] i have my phone
right now because that was like that was
like a home but we're throwing out like
premises usually that was killer yeah
that's a
done deal
oh he has a ways to go what do i have
all right all right let's see checking
the old see i got horse [ __ ] here
big breasted woman you mine are like
throwaways i got this one about liberals
uh
how they love guns and movies but but
they don't
yeah i ran this by norman the other day
i'll bring this up
i just want to make sure this wasn't
like a bit he had but i said you know
liberals love guns in movies but you
don't want to be near them in real life
i'm like yeah is that crazy that i can
separate the art from the artists
is that weird it's like uh you know i
look at guns when i look at r kelly from
an entertainment standpoint outstanding
don't want him near high school
[Laughter]
i hope you don't have a bit like this
because it sounds like it might be
something you would have but hey man um
having a one night stand with me is like
watching a trailer for the whole
relationship
you know
it might be exciting at first but then
i'll just totally uh give away too much
and let you down in the end i i don't
have anything like that but it's so
funny that i have a one-night stand bit
i just wrote down but no it's not okay
that's nothing like what i have that
does i feel like there's a lot more here
that's literally just the
bullet i wrote this down for one night
stands hold on uh it's amazing how
quickly you change your opinion of
someone after a one-night stand like the
night of i'm like i'll move to dallas
you know the next morning i'm like if
you died i would feel nothing
that's what i wrote down yeah see that
one has a punchline
this is a premise that's a good premise
though
the whole the whole thing encapsulated
in one night yeah like you know people
leave a see a movie trailer like i don't
need to see that i got the whole thing
you know that's what it's like [ __ ]
me yeah like i don't need to date this
guy i got the whole world the [ __ ] up
apartment the bad jokes you know the
small dick whatever it is but really
charming in the beginning
filled with lies and then the truth
comes out it's all smoke and mirrors
yeah yeah it's funny maybe there's
something like michael bay joke where
like in the trailer it's like oh my god
this is high production then you see it
you're like that's it right
no you only tried to get me in you
didn't this is a terrible movie yeah
yeah i feel i mean i relate to it a lot
where i feel like i'm very charming on
the first date by date number two
they're like that's it i know i'm just
so boring got nothing more right
do you ever have girls come to your
that you met doing stand-up and then
they do
they lose the charm of the stand-up
i had that once like that magic trick of
seeing you the first time and then they
quickly realized i try to push off stand
up as long as i can yeah i try to avoid
that because i'm like that's like a
trick that's like a hail mary if i need
it
i don't want to open with stand up yeah
i'm the opposite really i go all act
yeah i feel like yeah
if you do if you have a good set in
front of a lady i feel like it you're
like
sixty percent better off oh yeah in a
row in a one night what they see you
with a show great but i'm just saying if
you meet in other circumstances oh yeah
it comes straight to a show that's
[ __ ] mental [ __ ] i see no i was with
a comic in
at the store
i forget who it was and she
had three tinder dates in the audience
oh my god like they were three separate
ones that she had hooked up with that's
a that's a dating show by the way
it's like a limit but at the store you
fight it out yeah yeah
yeah they were all out there
eliminate was like it was like you
remember peter peters is [ __ ] smiling
it's like four chicks or four dudes and
like they'd all be like fighting for the
affection so one gets eliminated each
round
and you know there's always with the
women it's more fun because one will be
a huge [ __ ] and like by round three
they're like i'll show you what it's
like and they like make out with you and
you're like all right this chick you can
tell if the dude's looking for love or
he's just trying to [ __ ] yeah because
he'd always be like this one's looking
for the real thing but this one played
with my balls in the last round right
that's she's staying that's why i love
that show catfish because like they
haven't yet he's like i'm in love with
her this is the love of my life oh my
god i've never felt this way it's my
soul mate then he sees her and she's
like kind of chunky and he's like i
gotta get out of here
hey here's his bus fare we're in love
like oh my god you're a fat man from
syracuse
oh yeah what about all those new ones
like the love islands and all that oh i
can't there's too many [ __ ] boys
nicki glazer is hosting one i still oh
yeah people love it though people love
it i can't watch it dating reinventing
yeah i should i bet they're fun yeah i'm
sure they're fun who's time i know i
know if i want to watch a good i want to
know what disrespect to those shows
i want to watch something that's not
horseshit
you want to watch like a good i'm still
i still romanticize like the scripted
show i still love like mark was praising
the bear i wanna i'm gonna watch that oh
yeah everyone loves the bear it's pretty
fun yeah it's so wealthy it's great
they say that right and i work in kids
they say that everyone that works in
food services yeah what are your
favorite shows yeah what are you what
are you like now and forever like what
are you oh man um
forever shows are like the obvious of
like the sopranos the wire
um
breaking bad yeah yeah we said these um
yeah was it were there great shows
before streaming
i guess hbo was
uh hbo has been great for a while it was
the shield was fun remember the shield
yeah i didn't really watch the shield it
was cool oh that was a kind of a
groundbreaking i love walton goggins
though yeah dude [ __ ] rules it was
all sitcoms when i was young it was all
like whatever funny whatever
you know do you have a show that you
like is your comfort show on the road or
something or no
no
no i like garbage i like trash on the
road like anything like ridiculousness
or oh like
like really like i would never have
guessed it just throw on whatever as i'm
getting ready and just like leave it
because i don't you know
i'm not seeking out stuff to stream i'm
not when i'm on the road i'm just i'm
not taking too long i'm not logging in
and doing all that i'm gonna throw it on
i usually throw
and i was anti-ridiculousness because
i'm friends with daniel tosh oh yeah and
it was like it seemed to me like the bad
version of that yes yes but the girl
over in the corner that's laughing is so
cute she's very and it's just and it's
over here
where is tosh yeah that's just a mystery
we get mysteries about tosh because i
guess we have a crossover base because
we're yeah
because we're cruel white men but uh
yeah
what where's tash uh tash is still doing
the show
and he still goes out and does spiders
yeah i think i think it might be coming
i think i think it's a real test i don't
know how much comedy central sank yeah
man nobody really knows what's going on
with the biggest part with it is uh yeah
yeah
titanic sync yeah there we go
do you think it's needed or do you think
that it's do you think it's lacking or
do you think it's not needed
that
like the comedy central was a spot where
like young comics could get like their
first tv spot
thing and now it kind of like doesn't
exist there's no like i think it's both
i think it's not needed and it's lacking
yeah but i was grateful for it at the
time but yeah i mean we were taking
advantage of we were paid too little for
i think the material we gave up and i
think uh
they did their best to do nothing to
promote i mean like what do we do in
like 2014-15 or whatever like yeah
man that was a tough time to be on cable
and it's only gotten worse
yeah yeah and there do you think there
could be like a young comedian's show
now or do you think it's too blown well
they've got charlemagne who's a huge guy
on comedy central now they've got the
daily show they've got they've got big
names it's just south park and tosh
south park yeah i mean they're all huge
but
who's watching comedy central i i don't
you watch a clip online later probably
right i'm sure the daily show does well
on social and [ __ ] like that right but i
i can't imagine
are people watching the only time i
watch cable is for sports yeah yeah
that's about it
that's what i like about being in a
hotel on the road if you just flip
through and stop random what's your
garbage yeah justin what whatever
whatever like a person dropped in the
woods naked or whatever guys i don't
know
all that yeah
help me rhonda i love this song but
you're not gonna go by help me rhonda or
put that on at home no exactly hotel it
is it is funny that we've combined our
like job into like some sort of weird
vacation you got that right it is weird
i think it helps a marriage
i mean you're married don't you feel
like the road
keeps it gives you a reset it'll load a
hundred percent yeah if you will you're
excited to see it right yeah yeah yeah
if i if we were there all the time just
eating dinners with other couples i
don't i don't know
if it would last a lot of people are
just trying to fill the time you know
that's a great show detroiters have you
seen that a lot of these non-comedy
people they're just like oh
all they talk about is this this show is
out and this have you are you watching
this
uh have you tried this restaurant have
you gone to this bar right that's it
that's their whole life i know it's
horrible yeah that's a good show never
seen detroit oh my god they're they're
so those guys are both great and he just
got nominated for an emmy oh richardson
and tim robinson are so funny so they're
still
so why not put a
because they this app that they or like
you got to do the app
no one gives a [ __ ] about your app
comedy look yeah all right here we go
and you're done they've always
been like four lines of instructions of
how to get on yeah you're already out
you attract young people with no
attention span have them fill out a
bunch of forms
yeah follow instructions ah quick easy
steps get out oh my god
don't do it don't give them what they
want
they've taken enough from us yeah what's
your mother's maiden name exactly this
makes me want to read were you ever
sexually assaulted what are you talking
about
broad city they've always hit shows and
then you're like what they're behind a
wall it's like fort knox but do you
think that that like young comics are
getting shorted because there's not like
uh well you got the youtube thing that
we can do
youtube
social media you make your own destiny
it's a lot of extra work you know i mean
especially you want to stand out now the
production value on youtube's got to be
decent because you're competing like
i've always said that like i remember
with comedy central i did now we're
special with them and they were like uh
we'll put it out for free on our on our
website i was like oh my god this is
going to be huge for me i just knew this
would be huge and then they put a
commercial every two and a half minutes
and i was like okay i'm competing
against the best comics in the world
here yeah and there's no commercials on
these other ads
no one's gonna i can't watch my own [ __ ]
right now yeah but so
uh that that was tough i i think they've
made it really hard on themselves on
these on this ad based subscription
model whereas the the just a
subscription model like hbo or netflix
or amazon it's it's just obviously
easier and now maybe netflix is going to
have ads yeah they're going to have ads
now what
yeah
i think you're probably like hulu like
you pay higher to not have ads when will
that start they're gonna do it they're
they're exploring it now oh
this guy's got a special coming out soon
oh yeah finally i finally get in just as
this [ __ ] ship is sinking thanks
netflix did you record it yet it's done
yeah it's done [ __ ] that's good my
career it's done
uh no the the specials uh yeah the
special's pretty much ready to go nice
name uh it's called same time tomorrow
it's on netflix september 1st nice uh
yeah you know it's great very exciting
i'm pretty happy with it hopefully it's
not horse [ __ ] i don't know
i was just talking to cristela alonso
she has a special netflix that just came
out
relieved that's what he said like you're
never happy you're just relieved yeah
it's like oh it's out people aren't
killing it that people seem to like it
ah she's cool yeah she is cool she did a
great game
we should love it she's great i don't i
just don't know yeah i i never feel that
good honestly oh it's nerve-wracking and
it's just like part of it's uh probably
deeper than comedy but you're like
when do you feel good
you're working on it you feel bad cause
the material's not not there then you're
honing it you're starting to feel okay
because you're killing yeah then you
tape it you're sick of the material so
you're [ __ ] miserable yeah then
you're back to square one and you're
like i hate i'll tell you when you feel
good when you get that you get that
billionaire bit working
that's a good feeling when you get the
new one working that's great and then
killing is fun
but yeah you're right i never feel that
good though cause when you're killing
you're like well these should be killing
i worked on them really hard you gotta
you gotta you gotta get therapy on this
yeah you have to but you have going
tomorrow you need some gratitude bring
this up gratitude power force go in yeah
gratitude is key that's the thing that
kills uh envy and resentment and all
that it's great i'm not envious or
resentful i just i just don't like
myself i guess i don't want to join the
club yeah we're drinking at noon yeah
but uh yeah i gotta let it in i will let
it in you're right i hope it's
short-lived though even if you obtain it
sure well cause i i think you
the need for content is her quality in a
way where i'm just kind of like
wow i really have got to keep churning
it out and i feel [ __ ] burnt out and
then you're working it's like it's
hilarious we're like working on this how
you know stand-ups on art form uh i'm
working it out in west palm beach
yeah
this ain't a [ __ ] art okay these
people are shit-faced
i know
yeah but you know
i don't know it's the expectation of it
that kills it because it's look the
whole job the whole
career is
as i see it as just to creep create
stuff you're always you have to be stuff
for sure you're doing this it's why
you're doing your act it's uh you're a
funny little
character and you've gotta and it's your
job to make funny [ __ ]
yeah
funny little fella yeah and i had that
with the pandemic where you realize like
oh my god it's it's all gone now i
didn't realize i mean i always knew i
loved it but you're like i need this
yeah i need comedy i need stand up and
we you're up on a roof
you need it like yeah if it went away
you kill yourself so whatever i mean
look i [ __ ] i i was miserable but i i
was so grateful i mean we talked about
gratitude yeah i was like on those roofs
and i was like this is special just yeah
just surviving right sounds like you
were happy i was ah i am happy i was
[ __ ] around
but you do but you do get on those roofs
and you're like wow we lost so much and
now
yeah we really can't create our own
destiny in a way i mean you really if
you make your own [ __ ] i mean yeah these
streamers only have so much power over
us anymore now yeah i really can't say
oh you don't want it that's cool yeah
youtube exists
yeah we've built up enough people who
listen to this thank god and who uh
uh
and who
i guess like our comedy who who will
watch but uh yeah so netflix is great
and i'm and i'm grateful for the
opportunity but like thank god for
youtube thank god for other options
because tick tock
tick tock
dude i mean tick tock time with his life
span
oh okay
this conversation
i got another 30 seconds
yeah uh so you know thank god for all
that [ __ ] yeah tick tock youtube uh
instagram instagram all that i make a
lot of money on facebook just putting
out videos on facebook i will say
instagram
instagram though is and facebook it's
just poison the [ __ ] that they
pulled down you're like oh that's a
whole another women are literally
showing their butt crash
and you're saying that my [ __ ] is
harmful to the community oh really yeah
i'm like i got shadow band on instagram
because i posted a [ __ ] i do q and a
sometimes what's shadow band where it's
like they they bury you so you don't get
seen by as many people what like being
punished oh really i have to go sit down
and did they tell you that's what they
did or the numbers just go down
put your name in the search and it won't
come up but they posted that my content
is harmful
because uh i do like q and a sometimes
where i just say therapist sam which is
hashtag the rapist sam
uh
but it's uh i do like tell me your
problems and i'll tell you why it's
going to be okay it's like my little
like uplifting
but someone said it was a dumb it's not
even a good joke but someone wrote like
some guy hit me with a with a golf cart
and i said run him over with a real car
and they wrote this is inciting violence
you know it's not oh god i'm getting
punished by a [ __ ] robot and an
algorithm the future is bleak yeah
thank god youtube is not this crazy yet
i know yeah but it's going that way it's
going that way yeah
oh [ __ ] what happens when those things
all turn like into that because clean
comedy you can think you're a clean
comic and then all of a sudden right
no well clean is true no even if you say
something and it's misinterpreted
exactly i had a i had this
opportunity for this tv thing
and uh
someone took a joke of mine total
misunderstanding of it and
the opportunity went away
it was just because someone
who i never met or knew or they or got
to explain yeah anything
uh can you go into detail what what
network seinfeld was like that was my
[ __ ]
who explains mine you're finished it was
his bit uh
it was um it was a
tv thing i don't want to say exactly the
networks or any of that stuff um
and uh they took a bit you said or like
a joke or it was a joke in one of my
specials wow there's an old joke in one
of my old specials
um well if you're going down we're all
[ __ ]
you're a clean comic and you you have
bite i mean you're not at all like a
vanilla clean comic but you have bite
like any like 30 rock has bite
but your comic the joke was um
it was the beginning of one of my
specials and i
and
and i was i'll i'll i'll tell you what
the joke was but then also
um it was asian joke and then
when trump came out and said his [ __ ]
i was like i don't want to leave this
open for
misinterpretation
so let's edit this out for now
and somebody um
saw it but wasn't like i hate i was
afraid of like hateful people being like
you know if the joke is uh i don't like
chinese people
uh not some of them all of them
and it's because it's based on fear
and uh fear comes from ignorance and i'm
ignorant of that culture and that's why
they scare me and then i go into this
stupid joke about uh chinatown of like
eating uh like frogs or something yeah
um so when i wrote it i was like i i
want this to be a joke about being
ignorant of people's cultures you know
yeah and and get to the frog joke
and
saying i don't like chinese people was
the way to be like what what are you
saying and the crowd laughs because they
know it's me and you know i don't hate
anybody it clearly is a joke yeah so i'm
like i don't like chinese people not
some of them all of them and that's and
that is based on fear and fear comes
from ignorance and i am ignorant of that
culture you're explaining wow it's all
right there in the thing and also and
that joke and that you wrote people in
by like you build an audience you show
that you're not ignorant yeah and then
you explain your ignorance right and
there's still a problem and there's
still a problem and you're trying to say
you're trying to say this is where
people's problems with other cultures
comes from it comes from fear which
comes from ignorance and this is an
example of it in a lighthearted way and
um
and that joke
probably cost me
600 a year
damn
that's horrible because of one person
one person the incorrect way and we have
to cater to that one weirdo no idea who
they are no idea what one person in an
apple store uh looking office yeah with
slaves was like i find this joke to be
lacking in taste yeah and a kid jumped
out the window
and then he shot a chinese person for no
reason
so then they go through so as this was
as they were parsing it out
and i had shot all the episodes by the
way i tried ah it was already done it
was done and uh and then
and so then so they come to me and they
say what's with this this joke and i
said uh it's about the being ignorant of
people's cultures
and then i said um wow and just so you
know
a year before i met any of you people
um i was afraid when trump was being
such a [ __ ] about
china and the virus
i
took
that i talked to my editors
and despite them seeing no problem with
the joke i said let's edit it out just
in case it's misinterpreted by
some horrible people out there right so
when they come to me and they're like
and i'm like it doesn't exist anymore
like i don't know even how you found it
um
and uh
and we pulled it so then in the interim
as they're deciding what to do wait you
pulled this clip and they still somehow
found it and then tried to get you in
trouble yeah that's insanity yeah so i
mean you can't scrub everything from the
internet so they probably found it in
some you know some people repost your
specials they looked they searched to
ruin you they did so then to bolster
their case
they decided to go through all of my
[ __ ]
for 25 years 25 years
i hope whoever this person was gets
[ __ ] colon cancer including
untreatable i hope it stays in his
[ __ ] for a long time including all of
my rojos uh oh three hours of pop
um i don't know how many times ten times
i don't know um all of my stand-up
specials all of my tv appearances all of
my radio appearances
couldn't find one thing wow that's
impressive i couldn't find one thing so
you have
like if you couldn't find one thing and
the joke was horrible yeah child
molesting joke you'd be like well it
still outweighs it but you have a joke
that you that you're on the fence and we
pointed out this is about people being
ignorant of people's cultures and then
they go through all of that and they
can't find one thing that this guy is
doing shouldn't that be enough
that should bolster the case that should
do the thing
and they unreal bragged on dragged on
for like six months wow and it honestly
it's you know
it was my proudest work it was you know
it was it was money it was a money gig
um
so it's not like the money gives back to
other [ __ ] right and they
yeah they [ __ ] you in a sense yeah
they did pull it over that yeah
completely
and you're such a you're such a decent
guy i mean like i've known you for so
many years and you've never been
anything but just solid and if this can
happen to you
imagine like a guy with a ton of
podcasts where he says uh
horrific [ __ ] you know i'm trying to say
young friends mark and i will never work
in this town ever again
mark and i are finished
nobody but that's one of the quiet kind
of things where this is the first time
i'm telling the story because yeah it's
pretty much put to bed um yeah uh but
that's kind of like the quad like we
were aware of like the big time
cancellations of like you know people
being torn out for something that they
tweet or something after they've had
success or whatever this is under the
how much of this is happening oh at all
these young smaller levels protect their
neck fear-based horseshit what are they
what it is where they
they know that this is [ __ ] but they
have to do it it's not a dumb
organization right it's they go it's not
worth the mess if this could be any bit
of a mess it's not worth it for this
show and there were several parties
involved and then they went to like the
the big production company
that like
over the whole thing and that president
was like what are you showing this to me
for do you realize how many
how many people are coming for people
yeah every day
so much worse
this isn't a thing why are you giving me
this oh good this isn't a thing but
ultimately that wasn't enough wow what
does your agent say in a scenario like
this holy [ __ ]
what is going on what is happening to
the world yeah
if you if that's what i keep hearing if
if they're coming after you right
what did you consider
litigious
i don't think i thought about it in my
fantasy
but i don't know
how with that
on what basis well you just you know put
a lot of work into this it was in the
can right i got paid for that okay okay
well i got paid for that but
uh
yeah that's you know you just you can't
sue because your show didn't get picked
up yeah dealing with people who are just
cowards you're dealing with people who
uh
corporations who are places right
they're protecting themselves to the
point where like look
we don't like racism we don't like
[ __ ] you're so not that i mean
you're you're so clearly not that like
yeah the fact that you can't separate
that shows that you're just out of your
[ __ ] mind so the problem is not
racism but the fact that you can't
identify what racism is right well there
were a couple people
on the staff
who
came out and defended it who were
chinese-americans
who were like
it's this kind of false attacks on
people that dilutes the real problems in
the real asian hate out there so true it
really dilutes all of it so now you're
going to send you're going to have this
story as part of the narrative yes don't
stand up with a bit where he says i hate
jews and i'm a jew
and i've never for a second thought that
doug's an anti-semite of course not i
mean it's like
[Laughter]
yeah my point is yeah there's comedy and
then there's
real beliefs i mean like there's real
bigotry in the world
and instead of combating that you're
like we'll we'll do what we think is
helping it's not
you're hurting they're not they're not
even they're not even thinking about a
cause they're not they're not thinking
about defending i thought more by
by
uh editing my
joke and like putting it in a special
place to keep it off they're not
thinking about that at all no they're
thinking is this person
and i imagine it has to be is this young
person down the hall who works for us
going to cause so much [ __ ] yes exactly
and if this thing goes on the air are
they going to start up [ __ ] and be a
headache and we're going to have to are
we going to get dragged in because of
what this person this ignorant person
who doesn't have the um maturity or the
intelligence to parse what this really
is yeah
but are they
is it worth
this firestorm that they're gonna kick
up yeah and the sad part is this
ridiculousness won't go away until
companies stop catering to that one
person that's right sure and but they
still do because it's scary yeah and
they don't want to lose one [ __ ] they do
i mean that's kind of the beauty of
netflix is like it's the one place where
they're like
you guys have to act like grown-ups this
is
this is ideas this is whatever and if
you don't like it you do like all the
normal way of operating right i thought
about that a lot like special i have
like some pedophilia jokes i'm like if i
throw this on [ __ ] instagram they're
going to pull it down
on netflix but netflix
right that's alright it's a huge thing
that's huge that's a huge thing that's
chappelle thing whether you like them or
hate them was big for stand-up comedy it
was keeping that special on there yeah
and by the way i saw the numbers for all
the specials you know it's like
maniscalco bill burr seinfeld closer it
was like
drupal the rest of them wow because
obviously the controversy sparked
viewership but still it's like
just because you don't like it or
disagree with it doesn't mean it
shouldn't exist well it's like that
right certain thing remember back in the
day when it was like oh yeah how long
does the howard stern lover listen two
hours how long does howard stern hater
listen three hours or whatever it was
why they want to know what he's going to
say next yeah same [ __ ] for everybody
yeah exactly and yeah he's martin he's
dope by the way very good [ __ ] i'm
feeling it bro we've been drinking all
day yeah that's the idea right good job
martini
you know how they say about martinis
what right yeah
um
what is it
it's like uh it's like
it's like it's on a it's like uh
it's like tits on a cow or tits on a
whatever one is not enough two's perfect
three is too many something like that ah
that's up i think seinfeld wrote that
you know i opened up to you
we we bonded over uh because we i had a
faux pas with seinfeld as uh i've i've
told a million times but you got to tell
your steve martin one what's your steve
martin story um which one the
uh the gag you tried to pull
oh the by the way his new show is killer
man i just saw the first two and i love
murders oh yeah martin short they're all
so good selena gomez is amazing
yeah short is uh as a hero yeah he's
just still on he's still like
what happened with steve martin
i was uh opening for jerry at the beacon
and
uh
i hadn't been opening for him for a long
time and
we were gonna go and i was gonna open
for him at the beacon and then go to
this next city
um right after that and
uh i got there early and i'm psyched to
see jerry and stuff and you know it's my
friend from the road
and uh i'm in the green room and jerry's
not there yet
and uh
i hear the elevator you know on the
beacon night thing you sold out the
beacon recently right and uh
you hear that elevator coming up like
that horrible green room
dressing room section so i'm sitting up
in jerry's room and i
i do a gag of laying down like i'm
asleep like he's late so i'm laying down
on the couch
and uh and then the door opens and i
hear them i hear him talking i think
he's with his manager and they come in
and jerry's like
oh
and i opened my eyes and it's jerry
seinfeld steve martin and tom hanks
man
and i'm doing a a sea level bit
[Laughter]
what did they say hey how are you i'm
like hey
but then we just kind of like hung out
in the green room and i got bumped
because steve was going to go out and do
the first stand up he had done
wow in 30 years or something without
without the banjo he was gonna go and he
took my spot to go open
for jerry did you put up a fight
and uh and you know what i think maybe
ben stiller was there jesus i didn't put
up a fight but i sat next to steve while
uh
he was pretty nervous in
his list out and was like going over the
jokes he starts
reading me some of the jokes you think
this you think this is funny and
he's like reading me the jokes and he's
you know he's not really selling them
he's like it's like whistling when you
go away from your family on the road
and i'm just like you know
you have to say yes everything's funny
of course it's coming out of steve
martin yeah
he's a legend yeah my god
and uh
just being around that that upper
echelon of of that's like superstar
you're not just star that's you know tom
hanks was he cool steve martin they were
all ver they were all gentlemen they
were all really funny and they were they
were nice but chill you know everybody
was just kind of how about hanks
he's the best
yeah yeah he's the best he's like yeah
he's gonna make you feel great and
he's got like real empathy like he's
gonna
you know steve was kind of in his own
thing and like doing in and hanks is
like you doing okay over there you doing
all right you're having a good time just
doing it all right you're having a great
time yeah this is great until he's a
great he's such a [ __ ] icon yeah i
know
it's weird like what seinfeld is the
comedy hanks almost is to film yeah yeah
where he's just like so american yeah
classic like yeah norm and i were
talking because mark and i want to make
a movie
and we were talking about like classic
80s like back like bachelor party dude
that those don't exist anymore that yeah
we want to parody one of those like yeah
almost like that but that'd be a great
idea like a self-aware raunchy yeah
exactly yeah what buttons not to push
it's like they were cranking out fortune
i talk about it all the time like what
happened to like 10 comedies a year
exactly you know and yeah
70 of them sucked you know but they were
still like some laughs and john candy
show up
it was just like you cranked out comedy
but i i think everyone's a little
frightened about making comments of
course yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude i know i
i do you would crush people are
frightened guess what
that means that that there's a hunger
because your fear
fear what you're talking about with the
corporation you're working for fear in
film there's a hunger with an audience
and that's why the these podcasts have
exploded that's right that's why we need
a new comedy i mean
i think of todd phillips movies like
yeah hangover old school there's a
reason they blew the [ __ ] up i know
there's an appetite for that of course
and obviously like todd is a [ __ ]
beast i'm not saying it's not just like
anyone can make them but there was an
appetite for that yeah judd is another
one yeah where's the guy like making
hangover for half the money yes you know
just young people and cranking them out
exactly so you have to go to [ __ ]
china we can go to [ __ ] uh new jersey
we'll go to lithuania yeah
we don't even need a plane we'll just
shoot it at newark airport
but in slovenia
there you go yeah
what stays in czechoslovakia do you do
you have a peeve
a
pet peeve or anything yeah you want to
get out there i think we gotta wrap this
thing up here yeah about seven do you
guys have spots tonight we do i got a
couple yeah yeah seller let's go i've
got a nice sweet buzz on for these sets
sorry liz sorry liz alright comedy
cellar are you gonna let it ride are you
gonna
cap it i'm gonna let it ride yeah me too
what do you mean later ryan keep going
oh keep going you know keep a through
line drink when you get there yeah i'll
have i'll have like a a light drink to
even out to kind of ease it out yeah
yeah
yeah i don't like drinking and
performing i don't like it either but
here we are oh
this is my first choice
i linked up with this [ __ ] alcoholic
and
i got myself in a pickle
oh yeah start repeating jokes well the
worst of all so you guys ever whistle
that was the ninth whistle call back
we've done i don't care we're calling
this episode whistle while you work
[Laughter]
i stole the joke
what peeve do you have tom um i don't
like and i'm sorry to make it travel
oriented but um
that's where i live yeah we live for
these um
i just got a million miles on american
airlines wow and uh america i got like
like one email
and like 10 000 miles i saw a guy on
tick-tock and he hit a million miles
they like met him with champagne coming
off the plane they drove him to the next
gate i was like i got nothing
i really thought like balloons were
gonna or maybe the captain would chime
in hey tom's with us yeah nothing i
wanna be the tick tock guy or something
so they know maybe like a travel guy
maybe he was building it up yeah yeah
you're probably right but i don't like
when i'm sitting in the aisle
and
people come up and they want to sit in
they have the window seat or anywhere
i don't like that people don't use
excuse me anymore they just stand over
you yeah with their mouth a gape
and just
wait for you
to notice and it's really obvious on the
airplane because there's a string of
people behind and sometimes i'll just
quietly wait to see how they're going to
handle it yeah how are you going to how
are you going to get around just say
excuse me right just say excuse me i'm
in i'm in there for sure welcome
sometimes i'll give a little like jet uh
yeah be a human being oh man i'm on
flight with uh gary veeder last week and
like we just [ __ ] with each other the
entire flight so whoever's next to us i
genuinely feel bad for me
our characters are basically like
guy who gets whacked on the sopranos
shut the [ __ ] up you big mouth [ __ ] and
then fake shoot the other person people
like who are these
i'm coming back from the bathroom and i
i get through the seat vitor's in the
middle i just start humping him and the
lady's laughing so i'm like all right
we're doing something right
she's in the window
peter and i now do these characters that
we just call it like let's just pretend
to be the worst people on the planet
but the most peter
yeah well this woman cuts in front of
him she's in the row behind and he goes
this [ __ ] is cunning
she's gonna hear you and he's still from
long island
because his [ __ ]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
he needs some rodney outfits yeah right
dude i'll tell you when you're on the
road with your friend and it's making a
horrible extender
you get a load of hair
[Laughter]
it makes the trip fly by when you're
[Music]
it makes my my pet peeve seem very small
[Laughter]
it's funny well it's really good hanging
with you this is a great app you're the
best you guys are we love you i mean
tom's got so many albums online netflix
specials
one of our we've shouted match so much
so it's nice to have you one of our
favorite comics got a netflix radio show
on serious with fortune feamster
uh
i mean on the road anything coming up
the next few months you want to plug um
i've got a big show coming up in seattle
i'm doing two at the uh at the theater
up there i've got the wilbur theater in
boston nice beautiful i'm doing a bunch
of clubs through the summer of getting
ready for my netflix special
and uh yeah just tom papa.com i'm
everywhere one of the best comments
you guys are the best we love you we
really do and uh we'll be all over the
the country too what do i have when do
we when does this come out
okay i got a san jose los angeles
pittsburgh dania beach louisville irvine
omaha phoenix lexington new brunswick
oklahoma city springfield missouri fort
wayne indiana happy thanksgiving to me
[ __ ] you my agent kansas tacoma spokane
all over the place samurai.com
i love it hey mark is coming too
choo-choo providence comedy connection
improv in a west palm beach room uh the
aura in portland maine richmond funny
bone the amphitheater in brandon
mississippi with bert san jose improv
red rocks amphitheater
uh the dartmouth danforth sorry
royal oak michigan and uh you know it
rocks in theater that's in pittsburgh
pantages in minneapolis the revolution
hall in portland neptune theater in
seattle vogue and vancouver joy in new
orleans all kinds of stuff fillmore the
wilbur
zaney's in nashville say hello come on
by have a drink we might be drunk we're
in all the same places uh oh we might be
drunk pod.com for all the sweet merch
you got the cool glasses the shirts
everything the patreon is kicking it i
mean tom's got books out on amazon as
well check out his books i mean truly a
great comic
you guys are the best we love them we're
pumped to have you and uh we love you
guys at home thanks for listening thank
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
[Music]
my
[Music]